judge katanji brown jackson back for
another marathon round of questions
today on capitol hill jackson being
pressed by lindsey graham about her
sentencing in child pornography cases
you think it is a bigger deterrent to
take somebody who's on a computer
looking at sexual images of children in
the most disgusting way is to supervise
their computer habits versus putting
them in jail no senator i didn't say
versus exactly what you said i think the
best way to deter people from getting on
a computer and viewing
thousands and hundreds and over time
maybe millions the population as a whole
of children being exploited and abused
every time somebody clicks on is to put
their ass in jail
but don't worry the mainstream media has
already rushed to jackson's defense and
is lashing out at republicans for daring
to ask the judge questions about her own
record
the word i would use for tom cotton was
thuggish i thought lindsey graham was
screaming and weird josh hawley
ridiculous i mean quite frankly it
looked like i saw ted cruz commit a hate
crime that line of questioning which was
so grotesque from lindsey graham
republican grievance signaling
rgs it's amazing to watch someone who is
a
quite frankly an intellectual giant be
questioned by people who have
really no idea about the law
all right so i'll you know what i'll
start with you greg yes the judge in a
further explanation of her going under
the guidelines for child pornography
said you know the the fact that it's on
the internet which most judges would see
it as an aggravating factor and and that
the statute says you can consider it as
an aggravating factor she doesn't think
it is she said because you know the
statute was drafted before the internet
well what i find so incredible is that
she is so willing to look for every
excuse she can to get out from under
sentencing guidelines as it relates to
child porn and the more we dig into this
the more it's clear that she would
rather have a probation officer check a
guy on his computer than put him in jail
when the guidelines recommend jail well
i would say she's soft on crime
did i answer that question yeah thank
you very much i want to talk about don
lemon referring to uh the judge jackson
as an intellectual giant to be fair
compared to don a
plastic garment bag just streaming in
the wind is an intellectual giant the
yet the media is so much in the tank for
this candidate they should wear wetsuits
and snorkels
but to be fair this whole this is how it
works right there's a lot of
grandstanding there one side of the
media becomes the critics and the other
side becomes the cheerleader and then it
switches and then you know we become
nicer and they become angrier but we
were told by the media that this would
be a historic choice right after all she
is a black woman but how do you know
that she is
the media they're not biologists
we need to employ a biologist to check
every historic choice that is based on
identity i have no idea if judge gorsuch
is actually a liberal a white
libertarian do you could be a black
female you could we need a biologist to
check this stuff
out
let me get right to jessica with that
you know i really thought that you know
she ideologically she fits into the
court she's replacing breyer and then
all of a sudden she's asked by senator
marcia blackburn to define what it means
to be a woman
and she basically said she can't
and then thinks and she says i'm not a
biologist
what's the problem there
well marsha blackburn was on earlier
today with john roberts and he asked her
to answer her own question and she said
i would say i'm a woman i am a female
now judge jackson certainly could have
gotten that answer out but that wasn't
she was after but it wasn't what she was
after it was a gotcha question because
she wanted to talk about leah thomas and
she wanted to talk about trans athletes
and judge jackson rightfully so i
believe did not want to get in the dirt
and have that fight how is that dirt
that may be a case that they may decide
how is that dirt
it's a squeaky clean example
it was playing into marsha blackburn and
the fact that she showed up and did not
have a good answer prepared because i
know that you would want more than that
what she wanted was judge jackson to say
something about being born biologically
female that someone who was born with a
vagina whether they then transitioned
and became a man later in life so it's
kind of interesting that she said that
judge jackson said we need i'm not a
biologist because is it about biology
i thought maybe it's not about biology i
thought that's what we were talking
about i mean we all know what was going
on there and i that and she didn't want
her hearing to turn into screaming
matches about
the world culture
we're going to give her credit for not
answering a question i i i actually
think that with the hearings that we
have seen
recently yes i want to give her credit
for not degrading herself to having a
fight about these woke culture battles
yes i do want to give her credit for
because i have full confidence that
judge jackson thinks that people who
watch child porn are bad people and that
she could muster an answer of i would
say i'm a woman i would say i'm a female
yeah but she didn't and that's the
problem because she didn't have the the
the corjones obviously which is the
world
we should ask a biologist
i mean i mean and even child pornography
i think it's despicable but i'm going to
go under whatever a prosecutor says
whatever the statute says but because
the internet wasn't there well the
internet was there but jesse why don't
you just wound finish this up
if that's a gotcha question what is are
you a rapist that seems like a gotcha
question to me she should have been able
to answer that question jessica do you
think anybody can answer that question
smoothly if she's that brilliant spin it
say you know what i was born a female
because i have biological female parts
but this is a complicated issue now in
the united states of america and gender
is in flux because of this that the
other thing you're done and then that's
how you scoot through the fact that she
couldn't answer that question makes me
think maybe she's not as brilliant as
everybody says she is because that's a
slam dunk question and everybody knows
it i also don't like this thing the
democrats
breathe fire at these republican
nominees really nasty stuff but someone
asked her what the definition of a woman
is and the media rushes in and starts
giving chest compressions on her like
they're trying to save her from near
death
these things are so stacked you've had
republican nominees accused of rape
sexual harassment bigotry racism sexism
everything and democrats don't even give
him like a little sympathy vote all
these things are so over the other side
it's crazy all right dana but i just
wanted to add um i was gonna make some
media bias points but you did it so well
i am going to leave that there
i don't think that the
i don't think that they prepared well
enough
for this child porn issue on the
democratic side over at the white house
when they were doing the mock hearings i
don't think they saw it coming and i
don't think they've handled it all that
well i think that there are a lot of
people who say obviously this is
ridiculous that republicans are blowing
this out of proportion however
parents aren't going to see it that way
they're not going to hear it that way
and parental involvement in their
children's lives is the a number one
issue in all of these swing districts in
these swing states so let's just say
you're in a tough district and you
thought you were going to run on the
fact that joe biden had just nominated
and confirmed to the supreme court the
first black woman and this was going to
be something to be celebrated it is
however you also know you're going to
have to take a tough vote because now
you're going to be labeled as soft on
crime just like judge jackson that's how
those ads are going to run and this is
going to play well into the midterms hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else